[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es eine
klassische erdbeertorte das ist eine
torte die immer geht und ich habe wir
diesmal auch überlegt ich mache sie so
einfach wie möglich damit jeder der sie
nachmachen kann wenn man jetzt erstmal
im boden und das ist nicht mein
klassischer bizkit boden wir jetzt
vielleicht erwartet habt denn der bis
geboten wer ist zwar meiner meinung nach
auch einfach zu machen wenn man hier ein
schritt beachtet aber es ist halt so
dass man das eiweiß trend und separat
auf schickt und haben sagt sogar das
prozedere und heute euch überlegt wir
machen das so dass wir ein wunder
kuchenbacken der geht folgendermaßen ich
habe jetzt hier mal eine küchenmaschine
und gibt dazu alle erst mal rein ihr
müsst ihn nicht trennen einmal komplett
rein dann habe ich hier natürlich zucker
die gebe ich auch direkt mit reinen
vanille extrakt für den geschmack und
dann schlagen wir das ganze acht minuten
lang auf maximaler geschwindigkeit
richtig schön hält für mich
[Musik]
jetzt ist die eier zuckermasse hell
cremig und als nächstes rühren wir ganz
kurz unsere flüssigen zutat mitunter das
wäre einmal milch und raps stadt rapsöl
könntet ihr auch sondern verwenden
aber was auf keinen fall benutzen dürft
ist olivenöl zum beispiel weil das
schmeckt zu intensiv das ist fürs backen
in dem fall also nicht geeignet so
einmal rein und ihr weht auch anhand der
verpackungen und flaschen
ich habe natürlich wieder mal bei
kaufland eingekauft und dieses video ist
auch in zusammenarbeit mit meinem
lieblings supermarkt kaufland entstanden
so und jetzt höre ich das ganz kurz ein
paar sekunden und danach fahre ich mehl
und backpulver miteinander
[Musik]
die trockenen zutaten dann hinein sieben
und 14 sekunden unterrühren und dann
fühlen wir den teig in unsere springform
ich habe mir 24 cm springt vor dem boden
mit backpapier auslegen und so ein
bisschen glatt verstreichen und jetzt
packen wir unseren boden bei 180 grad
ober und unterhitze im vorgeheizten
backofen das ist ganz wichtig für ca 40
minuten und lassen ihn dann zu gedenkt
vollständig auskühlen
während der boden auskühlt kümmere ich
mich um die erdbeer creme die ist super
lecker und sehr sehr frisch den später
kam noch pürierte erdbeeren mit hinzu
aber jetzt erstmal zu schlagsahne die
sollte ganz kalt aus dem kühlschrank
kommt ich habe gerade auch schüssel und
schneebesen aufsatz in den kühlschrank
gegeben für fünf minuten dann kann euch
auch nichts mehr schiefgehen einmal
einfüllen und dann steige ich es erst
langsam und dann gehe ich denke
geschwindigkeit immer höher und lass
deine fest ein riesen bis es komplett
steif ist
[Musik]
jetzt ist die sahne steif die kommt nur
ganz kurz an die seite die restlichen
zutaten verrühren ich jetzt in meiner
schüsse da habe ich wieder unser trio
und zwar mascarpone mager quark und
sahne ihr könnt auch schott mascarpone
doppel ram frischkäse nehmen oder wenn
ihr sagt ihr möchtet den komplett
weglassen dann habe ich auch einen tipp
für euch dann ersetzt in die menge halb
und halb eben durch sahne und magerquark
ich schreibe ich euch ganz genau nochmal
in die video beschreibung falls sie es
jetzt zu verwirrend sein sollte war
einfach alles rein geben
magath war auch noch mit dazu und dann
habe ich schon mal erdbeeren püriert und
die sie sich jetzt auch dazu damit ich
diese kleinen stückchen nicht drin haben
[Musik]
für die süße und für den geschmack noch
puderzucker und vanille extrakt
abzugeben
und jetzt will ich will mein schneebesen
und verrührt das und anschließend habe
ich mit einem tag über die sonne unter
so und kleiner geheimtipp ich habe jetzt
hier noch ein bisschen lebensmittelfarbe
dazu geben
das ist ein geheimtipp nicht singen
wirklich so leise damit es eben auch
schön aussieht
[Musik]
unsere creme ist fertig die böden habe
ich zweimal durchgeschnitten damit ich
drei bilden der halte und jetzt müssten
wir eigentlich alles nur noch schichten
dafür nehme ich mir eine tortenplatte
also ich verzichten immer gerne direkt
auf den torten platten damit ich später
den transport nicht mehr habt so und da
gebe ich jetzt den ersten boden einmal
drauf spanne einen tortenring drum herum
und dann fange ich an mit ein paar erste
film der creme und was ich auch noch
mache ich möchte euch die geballte
ladung erb werden es gibt da noch
frische klein geschnittene erdbeeren
dazwischen wenn wir ganz oben angekommen
sind dann sage ich euch wie wir
weitermachen
[Musik]
die torten oberfläche jetzt noch ganz
denn mit der creme einstreichen damit
sie auch nicht austrocknet und dann
geben wir sie für 30 minuten in den
kühlschrank damit alles schön sitzt
schön fest wird und wir den tortenring
entfernen können dafür steht ihr euch
jetzt is back formloser geht da einmal
an den rand entlang und dann hebt den
tortenring an und dann haben wir noch
creme übrig ich hab das extra schon so
alles zubereitet dass man keine neue
creme anderem muss das heißt erst dann
noch einiges übrig und das brauchen wir
dann noch mal um alles rundherum
einzustreichen ist mancher moment okay
es gibt das so schön aus jetzt
vorgenommen hätte sie kommt jetzt
einfach raus ja komplett
[Musik]
selbst teile ich noch die torte einen 16
stücke und der kurier sieht dann mit der
restlichen creme in dem ich eine rosen
telefon wende
und natürlich kommen auch die oberfläche
noch erdbeeren ist ja ganz klar
denn der toten sind einfach nur hübsch
aus allein schon wegen der farbe und
wegen der frucht wenn ihr möchtet könnt
ihr dann noch ein bisschen kokosraspeln
darüber geben ob ich jetzt gerade ganz
spontan aus dem schrank geholt und noch
so ein bisschen darüber gestreut und
jetzt ist die torte fertig bitte
unbedingt bis zur bis zum anschnitt kühn
das ist immer ganz wichtig bei
sahnetorten und ansonsten lässt sich
einfach schmecken dies extrem lecker
locker also der boden ist ja saftig und
die creme sehr locker und das passt
einfach perfekt zusammen
die ganz genaue mengenangaben schreibe
ich euch wie immer unten in die video
beschreibung und dann sehen wir uns auch
hoffentlich beim nächsten rezept
hinterlässt ein kostenloses abo damit
ihr das auch nicht verpasst und dann
würde ich mal sagen bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss eure kiki und der hamza
[Musik]